hey guys how's it going so I'm with my
new friend Jack here hi jack hi jack
there's already one of those well yeah
there is sorry it's okay
so what are we doing right now cuz we're
in Austria and I don't live here
I definitely don't live here hmm we're
here launching for you okay
don't make fun so I have been calling
Jaguar Jaguar because that's how we say
it in America how do you guys say it
fortunately in Britain we say the Jaguar
Jaguar John good British accent that is
a strong British accent it's here for
the dude no okay went back very quickly
we were co-hosting this really fun
livestream and it was the launch of the
new eyepiece Jack the eyepiece it's an
electric vehicle we're really excited
about it well we're gonna do something
really fun we did one of these on your
channel where you were telling me
British slang yes I didn't do that well
oh you feel like by the end of it though
it was a good experience you've learned
a lot of British slang and when you come
to the UK next if you ever get drunk
you're gonna have so many words to
describe it I'll be fully prepared we'll
go check that video out on his channel
I'll put a link in the description but
now it's your turn okay do you spend
much time in the States
oh I am constantly trying to break
America Oh thus far I haven't made a
dent okay
but this could be the opportune this
could be it depending upon how well you
do also this is something else that
we've been talking about he doesn't
Drive either yeah which is problematic
in LA it is definitely problem you don't
have to drive in LA you do no one walks
in LA well no one's gonna let you in
unless you get some of these right so
let's look at a couple of these um
couch potato a potato that you consume
whilst sat on your sofa hmm no do you
want to like a couch potato say to a
potato because the couch is a relaxing
place it's totally eat and when you eat
it you just feel like you're at home and
you're sat on the couch it's a wonderful
warming homely potato uh well no it's
actually a lazy person who spends the
bulk of their time engaged in things
that can be done while sitting on the
you were halfway so close do you have
point okay half a point
I should do an alert for potatoes or
some for that whole foods and when I
talk about potatoes
yeah we've just got that Oh welcome
GameChanger it really is great I mean
I've never seen so much quinoa there's a
lot of Gerlach give a ring give a ring
yeah it's a we propose no well you've
been really no this is this is a
different to give a rainy summer yes yes
give it ring hyped hyped like up for it
buzzing excited I'm hyped yep a very
excited state I just waited it's a
really great spaghetti the other day and
I said I was hyped for spaghetti it's
really a dumb story it was a wonderful
anecdote I was only thinking because I
knew it was hyped for spaghetti hyped
are not high it's often spaghetti all
these carbs kymaro the way I'm shocked
do you know what chef means shook yeah
like oh I'm shook no is this a test this
is actually this is what the kids say
yes no yeah it's like a big thing I'm
sure as in I'm annoyed
we're like shocked shocked yeah I'm sure
like what I'm shocked I'm shook a piece
of cake Oh easy that's exactly what yeah
yeah I plead the fifth
I beg your pardon plead the fifth you
plead the fifth
this is an American football thing it I
don't know is it quarter than fifth
quarter no you can't but it's okay oh my
god that would be over time can we
please come a bit first quarter no
gorgeous for for Jack there for
definitely not a lot of you whether
you're gonna like get to like customs or
something
Oh plead the fifth something to do with
the Constitution yes the fifth amendment
yes but what is the fifth amendment is
it one of the weird ones like you can't
steal someone's cattle and so no they're
weird event I don't know the Ten
Commandment not come on here not
Commandments not the commandments I know
so politics and I saw Hamilton Elgin I
was so confused I just sang was oh we
should have focused okay so baby do you
want me to
okay put me out of my misery the Fifth
Amendment allows a witness in court to
refuse questions on grounds that they
risk self-incrimination if I spilled the
milk and my mom was like who spilled the
milk Justine who spilled it
I plead the fifth cuz you don't want to
say yes because then I would be myself
yeah
pass the buck would be all gosh is that
a no-no it's the only member we don't
have to mend okay we don't have these
kind of laws all just respect the Queen
it's pretty awesome Bobby
Zonk zonked drunk no you could be zonked
from getting too drunk beaten up you
probably potentially could have died no
no wow I'm so Zonk from running a
marathon tired yeah exhausted exhausted
yeah good I'm just reading off of a list
that I found and this one says pants do
you know the pants yes does that mean
something bad no well this is the thing
with time oh no I didn't read the rest
of the paragraph what do you call this
Charles's okay
underpants hmm weirdly my dad calls the
knickers
he's a 78 year old man and he refers to
mine not mine yes but he calls the
knickers he's like where your knickers
are on the floor picked them up that
sounds really weird as in like if he
when I was we'll go to the next one my
bedroom my bedroom was in a mess who's
that pick up your knickers what they not
make his girls wear knickers boys wear
underpants slowly whatever you choose to
wear is totally up to you Calma do I
just stand afraid my dad said people
make is spilled the beans I think you
already I know that spill the beans you
just told us that's great
these when in truth movement everywhere
I take a rain check
that's like oh I can't see you because I
need to take a rain check like it's a
will do it but will them do it another
time
yes yes that's good jonesing is it
seemeth Tom Jones sex-bomb Tom Jones
listen yeah the Welsh singer
ah yeah I don't know
we melt sing a bit sex-bomb sex-bomb you
can do many when you need to tell me on
he's like really famous ah play Tom
Jones oh my god that's amazing
really super futuristic I'm gonna use
all my data for this this is James II
know got the harry's chance to the
overseas right oh yeah
so I don't even know how many we did but
maybe we'll do one more what is James II
mean oh I forgot to tell you so saying
my sister has a really great person I'm
like I'm Joe anything for that purse Oh
Janice you want some people want any I'm
jonesing for it yeah okay one more
sorry house sometime James's lawyer we
I'm so sorry we won't actually play the
song in the video don't worry the last
one is this is actually perfect
ride shotgun ride shotgun yes um okay mm
nothing
don't ever do any goth you know right Oh
shotgun see it's you have to do oh I
didn't apologize why do the passengers
the car drive I ride shotgun
that's incredible well guys that is the
end of this water project even happened
I'm not sure but we also did this on
your channel too and I'm hearing to
watch it but yeah yep what's your
channel my channel
yeah is that where your but it was gonna
be called I jack but really that's taken
so it's just at Whitehall okay well I'll
put it in the description so they can
find it bye guys bye Wow
[Music]